what happened on the view did you leave
voluntarily or they did they ask you to
leave uh I you know I knew you were
gonna get to the juice of everybody in
this building um I I didn't leave
voluntarily um I had just signed I have
to be very careful about how this is all
said but ya know I I had signed for a
new season I think about like a week and
a half before it was super excited in
fact they released all this really cool
merchandise with all of our faces on it
and I was like I had just put a post up
like oh my god I've never been on a bug
before then my mom was like and it's
like a really tender spot but um no I I
don't know like I I don't know what
happened how do they let you know um Wow
enjoy the mug uh I got a phone call I
actually just got a phone call and was
kind of told but I didn't I can't really
talk about this I'm not supposed to
really get into it but the only thing I
can say is I don't know like I don't
everybody says well why'd you leave and
I'm like I don't have an answer for you
I wish I could explain I have a group
one thing I will say I have a great
relationship with everybody on that set
I get along with every single host two
of them were at my wedding I mean I
communicate with all of them sunny and
Sarah actually I'm sorry sunny and Sarah
were invited to the wedding we were very
tight Sarah couldn't come sunny was at
the wedding with her husband just close
with Whoopie like joy just texted her a
couple of weeks ago got along with all
the producers never had a fight there's
no drum everybody look at the view I had
zero drama love them all to pieces
even the producers like love them well I
had no beef is it inert but it's have a
phone call like that we've all got them
in our lives is like yeah yeah look we
love you we're fans but right now they
just the direction they want to go in
there's always and my manager falls for
it every time
he's like give their fans John shut up
no one's a fan and then goes you gotta
go but exactly sometimes you know ya
know I mean the one thing I will say
that was really nice was that I got an
outpouring from fans and a lot of them
were from liberals like I you know I'm
this libertarian conservative kind of
warrior and a lot of the liberals were
like we're really gonna miss you
like what happened and the thing that I
was just most upset about is I didn't
want people to think that the fans that
I just got up one day left and left
because I didn't want the tough debate
or I didn't wanna I love that stuff you
know and I love those women and I you
know I root for them at home all the
time I'm talk talk to sunny all the time
I'm like go girl you know I have no beef
I'll watch it to be occasionally I will
yeah if sunny tells me there's gonna be
something cool on I'll turn it on and
I'll watch her and I I occasionally will
flip it on were you there when Obama or
trumpeter I was not there was I was
there for Hillary Clinton oh that was my
last my last interview that I like that
day when you go to a lot a lot you
you're like you feel like you you never
feel less important because you realize
what it looks like when you're there
versus when she's there right Wow nobody
cares about me at all but is that a
nerve-wracking day especially for you
because I hear role on the show is to be
the contrarian to her and you're the
only one like nobody's gonna be on your
side but at the same time you can't say
anything that's like disrespectful
because yeah guest booking yeah it's a
challenge I mean it was definitely I had
to kind of figure I wanted to ask her
about her emails and that's the question
I didn't get out I asked her a portent
question I thought about how I felt that
she was a little tone deaf I felt that
the book read tone deaf and she really
wasn't acknowledging why she lost I
don't think she loved that question it's
probably not tone deaf is never good
yeah and then I said it and then of
course when I left you know I didn't
know that I wasn't gonna be there the
next week and everybody was writing like
oh did she have fired because of Hillary
Clinton and I was like what that was the
story that I was like I have no idea
like I don't think so I mean I I didn't
get any you know certainly didn't get
any scolding for that would make you
feel good though to know like okay well
if I'm gonna get fired at least it's
because Hillary Clinton was so offended
by my tough questions I was like imagine
what happened to me if I asked about the
emails No